hello
my name is Minh
gosh I run a lab at Stanford and today I
want to tell you about a new project in
our lab that we call full scope which is
a completely functional microscope that
you can make by folding paper let me
tell you a little bit of a background
about my lab I work in the field of
organismic biophysics so I apply the
ideas of soft condensed matter physics
to the complexity and biodiversity that
we see in our planet we primarily work
on basal metazoans where we see all
kinds of complexity in life-forms that
evolved on this planet and I'm just
amazed by the micro cosmos that exists
on this planet that we just live and
breathe every single day but there are
days that I'm actually jealous of my
astronomy colleagues and the reason I
say that is you can find a dark spot and
look up in the night sky and just with
unaided eyes try to comprehend the
vastness of the universe that we live in
and every single person on this planet
can have this experience very very
quickly but if you wanted to do that for
microscopy or the micro cosmos it's an
extremely difficult challenge so several
years ago when I started my lab I
divided my attention to another field
that we call frugal science where the
goal is to build scientific high-end
instruments but that are available to
every single person on this planet we
call this field frugal science primarily
because the tools that we develop are
trying to democratize the access of
science to every single person the
inspiration for this started for me when
I visited Gandhi's ashram ceiba gram
several years ago it was quite an
accidental visit that I stumbled upon
this picture where Gandhi is essentially
either looking at a slide for leprosy
leprosy or malaria I find this image
fascinating
because in one single image it captures
how science and society connects
together and how you can actually use
science to better humanity one of the
goals that microscopy is used for is
field diagnostics especially for
infectious diseases and the reason for
that is is most infectious diseases have
faces whether it's African sleeping
sickness or Giardia or Leishmania or
malaria they all have different forms
that you can identify using microscopy
one of the other reasons that I'm
interested in the field of infectious
diseases and Global Health is because I
grew up in a developing country and for
me while growing up I felt that the need
for scientific tools and the fact that
as a kid access to scientific tools were
only available to a very few set of
people so one of the goals and drives
that this project is to try to change
that in a little bit this is one of the
images of how society felt several
centuries ago when for the very first
time they realize that there is a
microcosmic life forms that all the way
to things that cause diseases to things
that actually make us alive here is a
picture of monsters depicted in the cup
soup of a British mom a little graph
from the 1800s one of the inspirations
for our project was large-scale
manufacturing so we looked at two
different techniques one is the art of
folding paper which is called origami
origami is fascinating because it allows
you to build complex structures with a
single set of sheet of paper by
primarily folding it the other
inspiration that we draw is from a visit
that I had some time ago to a matchstick
Factory where I learned you can build
billions of matchsticks and matchboxes
in less than a month primarily using
roll-to-roll manufacturing we utilize
both these techniques to manufacture a
unique kind of a microscope which we
call full scope so here is an image
or a CAD rendering of what the
instrument looks like I have the
instrument right in my pocket here is an
instrument that's built primarily by
folding a flat sheet of paper all the
optics and the electronics is printed on
this sheet and then it's folded together
to make a fully functional instrument
that costs us in parts roughly around $1
to make and we can do imaging all the
way from 700 to 800 nanometer resolution
we can get magnifications all the way
from 140 X to 2100 X one of the
fascinating things about these
instruments is the fact that it's design
completely independently it has a tiny
slot for taking traditional glass slides
the way you use them is using two hands
you move around for panning and the
tension in your hand essentially changes
your focusing so to give you a view of
what the complexity of this instrument
looks like in such a simple form factor
if I was to take this instrument and cut
this in a sideview what you would see is
several different components all the way
from a light emitting diode condenser
lenses several different apertures the
sample different optical lens
configurations for different
magnifications and all the mechanics
that goes in into making a fully
functional instrument to give you a fair
idea of what all the parts look like
here is a simple sketch so what you're
looking at here is what we call a sample
holding stage right here is the optics
stage and right at the bottom is an
illumination stage all the optics is
printed into these tiny little modules
which we use polymer optics or glass
optics that's printed in these little
modules that can be inserted folding
allows us to align these instruments
directly into one single sheet and once
the instrument is put together these
three different stages come together as
a single unit to just give you an
example here are the three different
parts cut using a die cutting process on
a piece of paper here is what we call as
a sample holding stage
is the optics stage with the optics
module actually put in and thirdly we
have an illumination stage which has the
light source a watch battery a switch
and an LED with a condenser lens on the
other side each one of these stages
folds and interweaves together to form
an individual microscope that looks
something like this it takes may be of
the order of 2 to 3 minutes to fold this
object in and folding gives you a fully
functional instrument there is a tiny
little slot right here that allows you
to put a glass slide so I'm just going
to do a quick test to show you how to
put the sample in so at this point the
sample has been registered to the slide
and you can image it very directly to
your eye either by looking right here or
essentially using this instrument in a
projection mode where the image is
projected outwards the way to use the
instrument is by both your hands where
you move your hands to change your field
of view and the tension in your hand
gives you focusing so just slight
tension in my hand allows me to move my
focal plane up and down to actually
focus tightly on the sample that I care
about there is a lot of number of parts
that go in to allow us the precision of
this folding that I mentioned and each
one of these instruments is then
manufactured using high throughput
techniques one of the fascinations that
we have about microscopy is this idea
that why not build instruments with our
own hands and then use them to see the
microscopic world we have done workshops
with kids all the way from very young
kids for example right here all the way
to adults where the goal is to build
instruments and learn how to make your
own optical instruments before you
utilize them this is very similar to
what's done in astronomy where people
build their own telescopes it takes
three to five minutes to build
instruments from
each one of these parts and to just
simplify the process we came up with a
color scheme that allows you to fold
these instruments primarily using color
instructions so it's kind of like a game
you fold together parts based on how
these colors come up on each other
they're ours no language or no other
instructions that are required other
than just following this color pattern
there are many different types of
instruments that you can make all the
way from bright field dark field
fluorescence instruments that can do 2
micron resolution polarization
microscopes it really depends on how you
configure each one of these parts
together here is a class of images that
I took from one of the microscopes that
I'd build a couple of months ago there
are lots of examples of images of
diseases here is an example of E coli or
bacillus low aloha malaria up on the top
right there but one of my favorite
images is this of an ant leg which a kid
while talking to her
ask me a question related to what is the
strength in an ant and there are typical
answers that you would give but what she
was interested in was counting the total
number of muscles that are there in the
sampling and as you can see what she
identified are these striations of how
these muscle structures are arranged in
a leg of an ant and yes sure maybe in
this 1800s in the 1900s somebody has
figured out and documented this but for
her it was the discovery of one it was
her curiosity that allowed her to ask
that question and using a very simple
tool get an understanding of her own I'm
going to now give you a quick demo of
what we call a projection microscope
which is really designed for sharing
images with a broader group of people so
I'm going to put in a simple screen
right here and just using the exact same
instrument right here with just a
brighter battery we're able to project
an image where a large group of people
should be able to share and see these
images live what I put in right here is
just a simple squashed head of
why and you start seeing all these
intricate structures this is really the
pump that allows flies to feed on sugar
right there and then I'm gonna move
around to show you something right here
which is essentially a filter that's
built in right on top of the fly's head
it's a bacterial filter you can start
seeing all these tiny little bristles
which act as chemo sensors you can start
seeing those tiny little holes in there
are essentially how flies breed and we
move around to find the optics right
here is the optical elements of the
fly's eye which is a compound eye and
you can start seeing each one of these
little holes they act as essentially
breathing tubes here is the neck and you
can see the entire surface is covered
with this tiny tiny holes which allow
flies to breed without just by diffusion
of oxygen
so what's fascinating about this
projection instrument is multiple people
can share images simultaneously and have
a conversation about what they're seeing
in a live demo one of the reasons that
projection microscopes are very useful
is the fact that it allows us to Train
microscope is out in the field on remote
diagnostics so for field instruments
it's actually important for these
instruments to be fairly rugged we had a
joke that we would throw these
instruments and indeed they do survive
several stories of a fall
they're extremely rugged instruments and
they are truly designed for field
conditions so I wanted to now end with
where are we going what is the vision
that we care about what is the vision
that we have is of a world where every
single kid could carry a microscope in
their own pockets at all times this is
very much like people carrying ballpoint
pens as a tool to write we've been
looking at this idea for the last couple
of years and sharing and building
workshops for how to build these
instruments and explore the microcosmic
world with everybody around you and one
of the factors that we have now
identified is the idea of building a
biology lab manual from the bottom up we
would like to recruit all most of the
order of ten thousand users from all
walks of life for a beta test which
essentially involves all the way from
teachers to kids to organizations
citizen scientists to traditional
scientists who are willing to
essentially run experiments and share
them with an instrument like this to a
much broader community I want to close
this talk by acknowledging some of the
funding sources that we have had and
point you to the website which has all
the details of how to build these
instruments the technical
details and at that same time a place to
sign up if you want it to be one of
those beta users thank you so much for
your time
you